TEST.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
YESTERDAY GAVE US A BIRD'S EYE
VIEW OF HOW STARKLY DIFFERENT
THE PRESIDENT'S PRIORITIES ARE
FROM THOSE OF THE DEMOCRATS.
NOW, YESTERDAY THE PRESIDENT
HEADED TO TEXAS TO FOCUS ON TWO
IMPORTANT ISSUES.
FIRST, ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION AND
SECOND THE ENERGY SECTOR.
HE HAD A COUPLE FUND RAISERS.
IN WASHINGTON, CONGRESSIONAL
DEMOCRATS WORKED OPEN THEIR
AGENDA WHICH WAS HARASSING BILL
BARR ABOUT THE MUELLER REPORT
AND, WELL, THIS.
THERE HE IS.
THE GOOFY HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE
CHAIR, ADAM SCHIFF TAKING A
SELFIE LIKE A JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL
GIRL AT THE HOUSE DEMOCRAT'S
RETREAT.
LOOK AT THAT.
IN THE BACKGROUND THERE ARE TWO
TRUMP HATING ELITES FROM TINSEL
TOWN.
JOHN LEGEND AND CHRISSY THIIGEN.
>> IT'S LAUGHING THROUGH THE
PAIN.
BUT IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
BALANCE THAT AND BE ABLE TO SAY
WHERE THAT TRUE PAIN IS.
>> CHRISSY WAS AHEAD OF THE
CURVE ON MAKING FUN OF DONALD
TRUMP.
>> I WAS.
THANK YOU.
>> SHE KNEW WELL-BEFORE A LOT OF
AMERICA DID THAT HE WAS A JOKE
AND A CON MAN AND A CLOWN.
I THINK SHE WAS MAKING FUN OF
HIM EARLY, LONG BEFORE HE
THOUGHT ABOUT RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: VERY CLASSY IF NOT
GRAMMATICAL.
I THINK HE MEANS PRESSIENT.
BUT WHO IS COUNTING?
IN HOUSTON, DONALD TRUMP WAS
HANGING OUT WITH A DIFFERENT
CROWD.
VISITING A UNION TRAINING CENTER
FOR OPERATING ENGINEERS.
THE PRESIDENT SIGNED A PAIR OF
ORDERS THAT WILL CUT RED TAPE
FOR COMPANIES SEEKING TO BUILD
OIL AND GAS PIPELINES.
>> WITH INCREDIBLE GRIT AND
TALENT AND SPIRIT, YOU LAY THE
PIPES THAT POWER OUR INDUSTRIES,
YOU RAISE THE BEAMS THAT BUILD
OUR SKYSCRAPERS.
AND YOU ARE THE MEN AND WOMEN
THAT GET UP EVERY DAY AND MAKE
THIS COUNTRY RUN AND FRANKLY
MAKE THIS COUNTRY GREAT.
YOU DO A GREAT JOB.
[CHEERS & APPLAUSE]
>> Laura: NOW, IT'S FUNNY, ISN'T
IT, HOW DEMOCRATS ARE SPENDING
MILLIONS ON CAMPAIGN CONSULTANTS
AND THESE RETREAT THINGS THEY'RE
DOING AND TRYING TO ATTRACT MORE
OF THE HARD HAD VOTERS THAT WERE
WITH TRUMP YESTERDAY.
BUT IT'S NOT A NEW SLOGAN OR A
SLICK MARKETING CAMPAIGN THAT
BLUE COLLAR VOTERS WANT.
WHAT THEY WANT ARE POLICIES THAT
HELP BUSINESS AND PUT MORE MONEY
IN THEIR POCKETS.
YESTERDAY SHOWED THAT TRUMP
ISN'T ANTI-UNION, BY THE WAY.
HE'S PRO WORKER.
>> UNION TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES
HAVE GIVEN ME A CHANCE TO BETTER
MY OPERATING ENGINEER.
MAKING MORE MONEY.
BUILDING RETIREMENT.
SECURITY.
AND HAVING GOOD HEALTHCARE.
THIS OPPORTUNITY AT THIS
INTERNATIONAL TRAINING CENTER IS
GOING TO PAY MY DIVIDENDS.
IT HAS BEEN A GREAT EXPERIENCE.
WE APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'VE DONE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP, TO GROW THIS
INDUSTRY.
THANK YOU.
[CHEERS & APPLAUSE]
>> Laura: THAT APPLAUSE WENT ON
FOR QUIT AWHILE.
I'LL TALK THAT HARD-HATTER,
BRANDON COOPER, AND HIS
CO-WORKERS OVER HOLLYWOOD ANY
DAY.
I BET THEY'RE MORE FUN.
WOULD NANCY?
>> I WAS REMINISCING WITH
CHRISSY AND JOHN ON THE WAY OVER
WHEN WE WON THE HOUSE THE FIRST
TIME, THEY WERE THERE AND GAUGED
ON THEIR WAY TO ITALY TO BE
MARRIED.
WENT TO ITALY.
WHETHER IT WAS AN EVENT FOR US
HERE, THERE AND EVERYWHERE OR AT
THE DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
CONVENTION OR AT THE CELEBRATION
OF OUR VICTORY.
JOHN LEGEND AND CHRISSY HAVE
BEEN THERE FOR US.
>> Laura: NOW TRUMP DOESN'T HAVE
TO BUG FOR APPLAUSE.
PELOSI HAS TO BEG FOR APPLAUSE.
INTERESTING.
NOTHING SAYS WORKING CLASS
AMERICA LIKE FAWNING OVER
CELEBRITIES TURNED
SELF-APPOINTED POLITICAL
PUNDITS.
>> MENTAL HEALTH LIES.
IT'S BEEN REALLY HARD FOR ME TO
DEAL WITH THIS PRESIDENCY.
THERE'S NO OTHER WAY TO SAY IT.
I THINK IT'S POSSIBLE TO BE
REALLY ANGRY ALL THE TIME.
I THINK IT'S POSSIBLE TO
CONSTANTLY WANT TO CALL OUT ALL
THE TRANSGRESSIONS AND ALL THE
LIES.
>> I'VE HEARD THAT PEOPLE WITH
ANGER ISSUES SEEM TO BLAME
OTHERS FOR CAUSING THEM.
YOU CAN'T FIND ANY JOY IN YOUR
LIFE UNTIL TRUMP IS OUT OF
OFFICE?
SOUNDED LIKE THAT.
IF THAT IS TRUE THAT IS TRULY
SAD.
IT'S FRANKLY NOT OUR PROBLEM.
BACK IN TEXAS, THE PRESIDENT WAS
SPEAKING WITH REAL AMERICANS WHO
HAD STORIES TO TELL THAT WERE
TRULY SAD.
RANCHERS THAT DESCRIBED IN VIVID
DETAIL THE BODIES OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS THAT THEY FOUND ON
THEIR PROPERTY THE PAST YEAR.
THE PRESIDENT WAS SO MOVED AND
SO AFFECTED ABOUT THE
HUMANITARIAN PROBLEM AT THE
BORDER AND ALL THE PAIN THAT IT
CAUSED LOCAL COMMUNITIES THAT HE
DECIDED IN A CLOSED DOOR EVENT
TO BRING THE PRESS IN.
>> I SAID WHAT CAN I DO FOR YOU
FOLKS TO CREATE MORE JOBS?
WE START TALKING.
THE FIRST PERSON THAT SAID SIR,
WE HAVE MANY PEOPLE DYING COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER.
WE FIND DEAD PEOPLE FROM
GUATEMALA, HONDURAS,
EL SALVADOR.
YOU SHOULD COVER IT RIGHT.
THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
POLITICS.
CAMPAIGNING OUR MY CAMPAIGN.
TOTALLY UNEXPECTED I HAVE YOU IN
HERE.
>> Laura: YOU SEE, WE DO HAVE AN
EMPATHETIC PRESIDENT.
HE'S ACTUALLY TRYING TO SOLVE A
REAL PROBLEM.
THAT ARE OPEN BORDERS ARE
CREATING.
HE GENUINELY IS INTERESTED IN
HEARING FROM AMERICANS THAT ARE
DEALING WITH THE FALL-OUT OF OUR
FAILED BORDER ENFORCEMENT.
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
PELOSI, SCHIFF AND THE ENTIRE
OPEN BORDERS CAUCUS, THEY PREFER
TO PRETEND THE CRISIS IS NOT A
CRISIS.
HANG OUT AT THE DEMOCRATIC
RETREAT AND GO TO YOUR YOGA
SESSIONS THAT LEAVES MORE TIME
TO HEAR FROM THE REAL EXPERTS.
>> DONALD TRUMP TREATS
EVERYTHING LIKE IT'S AN EPISODE
OF -- WHAT IS THAT MOVIE?
THE VILLAGE.
WHERE THERE'S THIS WALL AND
THIS -- THESE MONSTERS TO KEEP
OUTSIDE THAT WE SHOULDN'T TALK
TO OUR WE SHOULDN'T HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH BECAUSE
WE'RE IN THIS WALL.
>> Laura: BRILLIANT.
YEAH, THAT'S WHY THE PRESIDENT
SAID THE WALL SHOULD HAVE A BIG
BEAUTIFUL DOOR, FOR PEOPLE TO
COME IN LEGALLY.
DO THEY NOT REMEMBER THAT?
WHILE THE DEMOCRATS CATER TO THE
ENTERTAINMENT ELITES, IT'S NOT A
BIG SURPRISE.
OBAMA DID IT, TOO.
THE PRESIDENT IS WORKING FOR THE
FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN OF
AMERICA.
HE HASN'T ACCOMPLISHED
EVERYTHING HE SET OUT TO DO YET.
WE HAVE HUGE PROBLEMS BEARING
DOWN ON US STILL.
THIS COUNTRY IS BETTER BY ALMOST
EVERY MEASURE UNDER HIS
LEADERSHIP.
CERTAINLY NO REASON TO BE SO
ANGRY.
THE DEMOCRAT'S VISION BY
CONTRAST SEEMS DARK AND MAD.
THEY'RE INFURIATED ALL THE TIME.
THEY SEE AN AMERICA WHERE RACISM
AND MISOGYNY REIGNS SUPREME.
>> IF THERE'S ONE WORLD THAT
WOMEN USE MORE FREQUENTLY, WHAT
WOULD THAT WORD BE?
>> [BLEEP] YOU.
[LAUGHTER]
>> YOU'RE VERY GOOD AT THIS.
I'M SORRY.
>> Laura: THAT'S WHAT OUR YOUNG
GIRLS NEED.
JUST THE MESSAGE FOR THOSE HARD
HATS IN TEXAS.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'VE BEEN WAITING
FOR, ALL THE BLUE COLLAR PEOPLE.
I THINK NOT.
DEMOCRATS BETTER FIND A GOOD EYE
DOCTOR FROM THEIR RUSSIAN